verängstigt verzweifelt depressiv die
korona zeit macht vielen kindern und
jugendlichen schwer zu schaffen
nicht nur ärzte schlagen jetzt alarm
massenflucht in nordafrika tausende
migranten schaffen es bis in die
spanische exklave ceuta auch weil
marokko sie ziehen lässt und japans
ärger mit olympia der protest gegen die
sommerspiele in der pandemie wird immer
lauter
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievert an diesem dienstag und
danke dass sie dabei sind das schon mal
vorweg sport nachher in dieser sendung
mit katja stresow genannt kinder und
jugendliche müssen zurück ins normale
leben dafür plädieren heute ganz
nachdrücklich gleich mehrere verbände
von kinder- und jugendärzten je länger
die korona beschränkungen dauern desto
problematischer ist das für ihre
entwicklung sagen sie kinder und
jugendliche seien in der pandemie massiv
vernachlässigt worden die ärzte
beobachten zitat psychiatrische
erkrankungen in einem ausmaß wie wir es
noch nie erlebt haben
pablo salahi berichtet über ein jahr
schon leben kinder und jugendliche im
krisenmodus kein schulalltag der halt
gibt kein sport im verein und auch ein
treffen mit freunden geht nicht mehr so
ohne weiteres das hinterlässt spuren
jeder dritte jugendliche ist psychisch
auffällig über 80 prozent fühlen sich
durch die korona krise belastet noch
mehr als die erwachsenen sind sie auf
gesellschaft angewiesen
man kann jetzt die körperlichen und
psychischen denken dann ist es ganz
wichtig im kopf zu behalten dass kinder
und jugendliche natürlich viel mehr
entwicklungsphasen durchlaufen als wir
das als erwachsene tun und diese
entwicklungsphasen brauchen natürlich
soziale kontakte einen ansturm
verzeichnen kinder und jugendpsychiatrie
wie die rheinhessen fachklinik in
rheinland-pfalz während an anderen orten
wegen überfüllung patienten schon
ausgewählt werden müssen wurde hier
bislang niemand abgewiesen
also akut gefährdet den patienten werden
direkt gut behandelt wir sind noch nicht
an einen kritischen punkt angekommen
aber wir sehen eben einen deutlichen
anstieg
das heißt wir haben über becken wie es
geht über die kapazitäten hinaus aber es
ist nicht so dass wir jetzt passieren
recht abweisen die in einem kritischen
zustand am meisten helfen kindern und
jugendlichen die rückkehr in ein
normales leben in den regelbetrieb an
schulen und kitas so die zuständige
ministerin auf jeden fall müssen wir
jetzt mitdiskutieren wenn wir über
öffnung von außengastronomie und anderen
dinge sprechen das ist dann genauso
wichtig dass die kinder wieder in ihren
regel haften alltag kommen können zurück
in den alltag das ist das ziel
doch auch dann werden bei vielen kindern
und jugendlichen die wunden der korona
krise wohl noch bleiben
die zahl der neuen infektionen in
deutschland geht unterdessen weiter
zurück auch die sieben tages incidents
sinkt leicht und beim thema impfen hat
der bundesgesundheitsminister ja
angekündigt die impf priorisierung ab
siebter juni ganz aufzuheben
doch schon jetzt warten noch millionen
impfwillige der sehr großen
priorisierung gruppe 3 auf termine dazu
gehören menschen ab 60 außerdem zum
beispiel kassiererinnen und kassierer
mitarbeiter von verwaltungen banken und
versicherungen welche herausforderungen
es da gibt zeigt jana becker jetzt aus
nordrhein westfalen im kölner
impfzentrum können sich aktuell nur
menschen impfen lassen
die in eine der drei priorisierung
gruppen fallen tina dietz arbeitet im
maklerbüro hat viel kundenkontakt so
hatten die kölnerin und ihr mann heute
die chance moderner verabreicht zu
bekommen
wahrscheinlich wird es schwieriger
werdenden termin zu bekommen noch wird
in allen impfzentren streng nach
priorisierung geimpft wer wann dran
kommt das regeln die länder
unterschiedlich in nrw können menschen
selbstständig online termine ausmachen
vorausgesetzt sie sind priorisiert für
die arztpraxen haben einige bundesländer
die priorisierung schon aufgehoben
ab dem siebten juni soll sich dann jeder
einen termin sichern können
das heißt dass die bundesebene
verordnung wo es jetzt mal vor mal
auszudrücken keine poesie romer
beinhaltet punkt und damit gibt es keine
priorisierung mehr werden wir nicht in
den ländern neu geschaffen
aber das habe ich nicht vor die
hausärzte sehen dem siebten juni mit
gemischten gefühlen entgegen dass wir da
relativ viel anstrengung in den praxen
fliegen
die jetzt schon sehr stark belastet sind
wir hoffen dass wir wenigstens den
impfstoff so vollständig bekommen das
wird tatsächlich alles machen können um
so viele leute wie möglich so schnell
wie möglich impfen zu können
neben der frage nach den im kapazitäten
wird der ethikrat auch
gerechtigkeitsfragen in den raum wenn
man vorzeitig die priorisierung aufs
laufen lässt das heißt bevor die
priorisierten gruppen alle das berühmte
angebot bekommen haben dann heißt das
natürlich dass die risikogruppen mit
mehr menschen um impftermine
konkurrieren
und das sehe ich durchaus kritisch dass
die terminvergabe zur krone impfung ab
dem siebten juni für alle geöffnet sein
soll bedeutet jedoch keinesfalls dass
jeder auch zeitnah geimpft wird
aber den ersten schritt kann schon bald
jeder tun um das thema impfen geht es
auch bei zdf heute live ab 19.30
sprechen die kollegen unter anderem mit
einem experten der erklärt nach welcher
logik in impfzentren termine vergeben
werden und sie können mitdiskutieren in
der zdf- heute- app und auf unseren
social media kanälen viele bauen darauf
dass die impfung das ticket für freies
reisen im sommer wird die eu berät
deshalb über einen einheitlichen
nachweis einen digitalen corona impfpass
soll den herkömmlichen gelben im pass in
deutschland ergänzen
klar ist dass eu im zertifikat kommt in
form eines kostenlosen kostenlosen
qr-codes wer vollständig geimpft gewesen
oder negativ getestet ist kann das so
nachweisen
doch es gibt auch noch streit eine
klinik in griechenland ist der
sommertraum längst wirklichkeit am
letzten wochenende sind die ersten
touristen gelandet ein negativer
pcr-test reicht den griechen für die
einreise schon bald könnte das reisen
für alle eu bürger einfacher werden mit
dem grünen eu imf zertifikat eine app
die jeder der vollständig geimpft
negativ getestet oder genesen ist auch
sein smartphone laden kann die daten
gespeichert in einem eu-weit lesbaren
qr-code gestritten wird zwischen
eu-parlament und mitgliedsstaaten noch
darüber ob die pcr tests für den
impfpass kostenlos sein sollen
ob impfpass inhaber
zudem noch in manchen mitgliedstaaten in
quarantäne müssen und ob auch impfstoffe
die nicht in der gesamten eu zugelassen
sind anerkannt werden
die parlaments- position eindeutig klar
muss sein dass wenn jemand so ein
zertifikat in seinen händen hält
dass er dann auch die vorteile der
freiheit der reise der bewegungsfreiheit
auf diesem kontinent wieder genießen
kann das heißt seine rechte
zurückbekommt gibt es eine einigung
müssen die eu mitgliedsländer ihre
nationalen apps mit impf daten ihrer
bürger füttern
einer der eu klassenbesten ist bislang
schweben hier wird jede spritze sofort
in ein digitales imf register
eingetragen
deutschland dagegen hinkt hinterher es
gibt kein zentralregister sondern
unterschiedliche kompetenzen und regeln
zettel und aufkleber im 11 buch nur
wenige daten sind digitalisiert gibt der
sprecher des gesundheitsministers also
das was wir zurzeit machen ist zu
versuchen dass wir die impfungen
insofern digitalisieren dass wir die auf
einem zertifikat darstellen können und
das fehlt in der zweiten hälfte des
zweiten vertrag sein heißt noch ist
nichts digital
die deutschen fordern nun eine
sechswöchige übergangsfrist zum
nacharbeiten
das könnte für den sommerurlaub ganz
schön knapp werden
unser nächstes thema heute abend im
nahen osten sterben weitere menschen in
dem konflikt zwischen israels militär
und radikalen palästinensern ungeachtet
aller diplomatischen bemühungen die
gewalt zu stoppen
eine rasche waffenruhe scheint nicht in
sicht im westjordanland folgten viele
arabische israelis und palästinenser
einem streikaufruf und legten die arbeit
nieder axel sturm berichtet hahn iha war
in weiß selbst nicht so genau wer die
leckeren pickles heute kaufen soll
aber immerhin der laden in dem er
arbeitet ist geöffnet im gegensatz zu
vielen anderen denn die meisten
arabischen geschäfte bleiben hier in
jaffa heute zu generalstreik wir sind
hier an einem platz an dem man nicht
schließen kann
wir müssen auf machen damit wir geld
verdienen es kommen nicht viele kunden
aber wir müssen auch auf unser image
achten
es wird keinen akbar keine katastrophe
mehr geben steht auf dem schild sie
meinen die vertreibung der palästinenser
nach der gründung israels 1948 sie
meinen aber noch mehr
wir streiken heute um den zorn und den
schmerz auszudrücken den wir als
arabische bevölkerung verspüre
es geht um gaza um israels vorgehen und
wiederum um mehr die menschen hier
demonstrieren nicht nur wegen des
konflikts im gazastreifen
sie sind auch auf der straße wegen der
wie sie es nennen jahrzehntelangen
unterdrückung aller arabischen israelis
im land es brodelt längst nicht mehr in
israel und den palästinenser-gebieten es
brennt alter frust und neue wut im
westjordanland dutzende demos gewalt
hass bei hebron erschossen israelische
soldaten einen mann der mit sprengstoff
und messer auf sie zu läuft während im
gazastreifen weiter raketen aufsteigen
und zwei menschenleben auf israelischer
seite fordern greift israel weiter ziele
im gazastreifen an
eine lösung eine beruhigung der lage
beides nach wie vor nicht in greifbarer
nähe
und jetzt schauen wir auf einen
politischen streit mit enormen folgen
ein konflikt zwischen marokko und
spanien hat eine flüchtlings chaos
ausgelöst mehr als 6000 menschen aus
marokko sind die wenigen meter in die
spanischen nordafrika-exklave ceuta
geschwommen so viele wie noch nie
innerhalb eines tages
der grund marokko hat aufgehört die
grenze zu kontrollieren ganz offenbar um
druck auf spanien zu machen
hintergrund ist ein alter dauerstreit um
die machtverhältnisse in einer ganz
anderen region nämlich der westsahara
details jetzt von thomas walde
tränengas gegen steine würfe spanische
soldaten wollen verhindern dass
flüchtlinge aus marokko in die exklave
mutter kommen
in den vergangenen tagen waren tausende
herüber geschwommen und viele weitere
wollen es versuchen
trotz der gefahren ich habe keine angst
würde hier bleiben hätte ich angst ich
muss gehen um mich zu retten
wir gehen rüber entweder sterbe ich oder
ich schaffe es spanische soldaten und
polizisten haben unterdessen begonnen
flüchtlinge abzuschieben
meine priorität als regierungschef von
spanien ist es die kontrolle der
spanisch marokkanischen grenze zu
garantieren und so fort ich wiederhole
sofort alle auszuweisen die irregulär
gekommen sind und raúl an
zuvor hatte marokko unangekündigt die
grenzkontrollen gelockert als
grundwerten beobachter dass spanien im
krankenhaus von logroño den chef der
polisario behandeln lässt sie kämpft mit
waffen für die unabhängigkeit der
westsahara eines territoriums dass
marokko annektiert hat die marokkanische
regierung nutzt diese drohungen mit
migrations flüssen um ein politisches
ziel zu erreichen
in diesem fall ist das politische ziel
ein protest auch die eu-kommission
forderte marokko hatte auf die grenze zu
sichern
anfragen nach einer stellungnahme
blieben auf marokkanischer seite
unbeantwortet ja weil überwanden weitere
menschen die grenzzäune aber es waren
weniger als gestern
nach deutschland verteidigungsministerin
annegret kramp karrenbauer hat
reformvorschläge für die bundeswehr
vorgelegt dabei gehe es weniger um stab
mehr truppe und mehr eigenverantwortung
so genannte kräfte der ersten stunde
müssten insbesondere an den außengrenzen
des bündnisses also der nato schnell
eingesetzt werden können sagt die
ministerin
die grünen nennen die reformpläne
zwingend und längst überfällig eine
aktuelle aufgabe der bundeswehr ist der
rückzug aus afghanistan weil die nato
dort spätestens bis zum september ihre
mission beendet haben will
jetzt hat der transport von material und
ausrüstung begonnen am nachmittag kam
bei leipzig eine erste ladung mit waffen
munition und technik an
außerdem an bord zwei
transporthubschrauber im ganzen wird es
wohl 800 container brauchen für das
material das in fast 20 jahren
afghanistan-einsatz zusammengekommen ist
in rheinland pfalz ist die
spd-politikerin malu dreyer wieder zur
ministerpräsidentin gewählt worden
auf der konstituierenden sitzung des
landtags erhielt die 60-jährige alle 55
stimmen ihrer koalition
weiland pfalz ist derzeit das einzige
bundesland in dem ein dreierbündnis aus
spd grünen und fdp regiert die ampel
koalition gibt es bereits seit 2016
weiteres wichtiges thema jetzt die
digitalisierung home office einkaufen
von zu hause schulunterricht online
spätestens mit der pandemie wurde klar
wie sich unser alltag bildung arbeit neu
organisiert aber auch wie viele probleme
ist da noch gibt darum ging es heute auf
einem digital gipfel mit politik und
wirtschaft in berlin sven ricken zeigt
die möglichkeiten der technik und den
aktuellen stand
dieses projekt kann leben retten eine
drohne die noch während einer laufenden
krebsoperation gewebeproben ins labor
fliegt oft genug stecken diese
transporte im stau fest dabei geht es um
sekunden
der medizinische lufttransport ist viel
schneller und sicherer
die drohne aber braucht eine stabile
netzwerkverbindung sobald wir irgendwo
aufs land hinaus gehen und vielleicht
auch das land mit anschließen wollen an
die städtische infrastruktur benötigen
wir auch da flächendeckende und
mobilfunk abdeckung damit wir drohen
in diese prozesse sind voll integrieren
kann
in hamburg reichen die funknetze entlang
der flugstrecke schon heute aber eben
nur dort schnelles internet überall ist
ein zukunftsthema künstliche intelligenz
ein anderes was werden maschinen im
jahre 2030 können solche anwendungen
sind zwar nur spielereien aber sie
zeigen was geht auch dieser bus zwar
noch vor fünf jahren zukunftsmusik ab
dem spätsommer aber fährt das heat
projekt besucher der hamburger
elbphilharmonie vom parkhaus zum konzert
fahrerlos dafür wurde in hamburg extra
viel technik aufgebaut das schritt für
schritt sich das system so entwickelt
dass wir 2030 glücklich in großen teilen
gerade was den kleinbus bereich angeht
dort auch autonome fahrzeuge gesehen
werden und damit das it projekt aber
auch in anderen regionen fahrgäste
einsammeln kann sind hohe investitionen
nötig der kleine bus erzeugt nämlich so
viel daten in der minute wie ein
normaler pc nutzer in einem jahr und
jetzt ein fahndungserfolg der polizei in
dresden knapp eineinhalb jahre nach dem
kunstdiebstahl im berühmten grünen
gewölbe ist ein fünfter verdächtiger
gefasst worden bei einer razzia in
berlin
von der beute fehlt weiter jede spur
thomas bärsch
es war heute mittag 13.30 als abdullah
in dresden einem haftrichter vorgeführt
wurde der termin markiert für die
ermittler einen etappensieg
nunmehr sind alle fünf dringend
tatverdächtigen beschuldigten in diesem
fall in untersuchungshaft abdullah
gehört mutmaßlich zur gruppe der
einbrecher die im november 2009 10
dresden einen schock versetzt
sie hatten ein gitterfenster des grünen
gewölbes aufgesägt und schmuckstücke
entwendet teilt 300 jahre alt von
unschätzbarem wert es waren praktisch
sachsens kronjuwelen ein jahr später
fasste die polizei in berlin erste
verdächtige
sie gehören zu einem arabisch stämmigen
berliner clown manche seiner mitglieder
sind schon für ähnliche straftaten
verurteilt die festnahme des letzten
verdächtigen nährt nun in dresden einen
wunsch unserer hoffnung steigt dass wir
doch vielleicht auch die juwelen wieder
an den angestammten platz zurück bringen
kann
doch die verdächtigen schweigen und
bislang bleiben die kunstgegenstände
verschwunden experten fürchten dass die
exemplare zerstört und die diamanten
einzeln verkauft wurden
damit sind wir jetzt heute beim sport
katja gut zwei monaten sollen in tokio
die olympischen sommerspiele stattfinden
und während sich weltweit tausende
sportler und sportlerinnen auf das
ereignis vorbereitet werden die stimmen
in japan die eine absage der spiele
fordern immer zahlreicher und lauter
fast täglich proteste
jetzt hat auch tokios ärztevereinigung
bedenken angemeldet wegen hohe
infektionszahlen in japan hatte bereits
vizepräsident thomas bach seine für mai
geplante reise ins gastgeberland
verschieben müssen
bach kann nicht kommen und das zeigt
dass er erkennt dass japan in corona
notstand ist umfragen zufolge sind mehr
als 70 prozent der japaner gegen die
spiele
wer entscheidet tokios gouverneur in
yuriko ecke bekäme bei einem nein wohl
reichlich gegenwind von investoren ioc
und funktionären leichtathletik
weltverbands präsident sebastian co
selbst olympiasieger vertritt die
sportler seite
70 prozent der olympia teilnehmer
schaffen es nur einmal zu den spielen
ich denke wir sollten jede anstrengung
in kauf nehmen ich bin überzeugt wir
können die spiele sicher machen
eine absage würde auch den paralympics
die bühne nehmen
doch ist es ein großes geheimnis dass
aber morgen mittag gelüftet wird
die rede ist vom deutschen kader für die
fußball em bundestrainer löw darf corona
bedingt 26 spieler und damit drei mehr
als sonst dominieren die mit abstand
meist diskutierte frage wird er
zurückkehren thomas müller der beste tor
vorbereiter in der bundesliga schon
anfang märz hatte der seine bereitschaft
durchblicken lassen ich habe natürlich
auch große lust da um den titel zu
kämpfen wenn ich wenig davon
dementsprechend schaue ich da
zuversichtlich in den nächsten wochen
und monate auf 2100 die gerade den dfb
pokal in die luft gestemmt haben melden
sich bereit für große taten mats hummels
der abwehrstratege und marco reus
letzten spitze im sturm für spannung
jedenfalls ist gesorgt bis morgen und
vielleicht hält jogi löw ja noch die ein
oder andere überraschung versteckt
morgen 12 30 sind wir schlauer
dann kommt ja mehr kühles und nasses
wetter hat es wenn terry leider gleich
im angebot nach uns dann empfehle ich
ihnen das heute schon mit der kollegin
marietta slomka um 21 uhr 45 und von uns
allen im team 19 uhr bis morgen aber
erst machen sie sich ein angenehmer
[Musik]
ein symbol ahnte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter unterkühlt geht es morgen
tagesverlauf weiter bei uns mit
temperaturen um die 15 grad marke so
sieht's auch im norden europas aus aber
deutlich heißer im südwesten europas
dort bis 35 grad in spanien und 30 grad
in russland zum beispiel hier um moskau
herum aber diese hitze dort wird
allmählich verdrängt mit kräftigen
schauern und gewittern und erreicht das
nächste tief zum wochenende und das
bringt wieder kühle luft mit schauen wir
in die nacht da werden die letzten
schauer und gewitter allmählich
verschwinden und es bildet sich dann
nebel die temperaturen sinken dabei auf
werte von 4 grad im vogtland und auch in
der eifel zum beispiel sieben bis acht
grad im osten deutschlands und morgen
tagesverlauf wieder auflebende schauer
und gewittertätigkeit aus west bis
südwest die können auch kräftiger
ausfallen ganz im norden scheint die
sonne bei höchsten temperaturen bis 17
grad ganz im osten und elf grad an den
alpen ja und die nächsten tage am
donnerstag lockert es von westen her auf
im südosten gibt es schauer und gewitter
bei 11 bis 17 grad ja und am freitag
kommen wieder schauer und gewitter von
westen her ein schöner abend